foreign
Louis Missouri St Louis
St Louis how do you say it St Louis St
Louis oh it's not Louisville no yeah
that's in Kentucky Louisville
all right we're gonna go to St Louis
Missouri and talk to Erica cause it's
spelled with a K what's up Erica
uh well
um I'm kind of conflicted
um I guess I'll start with a question
first so my question is
do I have a right to feel jealous of my
husband's relationship with his sister
that's a good question hey I I
hear this one more than people would
expect
um okay good and I'll be honest it's 50
50. sometimes when I hear it out
I get really frustrated that the
person's even asking this question
because it's about jealousy about my
husband's mine I don't want him to have
inside jokes and laughter with other
people just me there's that and then the
other half of them is husband's a little
bit insane
and
almost relies on sister like uh like a
mother figure a maternal figure and wife
gets left out so tell me tell me what's
going on in your world
well I feel awkward and a little upset
of even having to ask this question
because I love my sister-in-law very
much we actually have a really tight
relationship and she's an angel like
she's beautiful she's intelligent she's
accomplished she's friendly she's just
amazing why don't you like her
well I love her that's the that's why
I'm conflicted with feeling jealous of
the relationship between her and my
husband
um so I'll start my husband is one of
ten kids
they were raised in a really strict
um home and a really strict
um religious update
so my husband is the second oldest and
uh the oldest brother didn't necessarily
take on his role very well he was just
not really into the whole family thing
so didn't treat the other brothers and
sisters well so my husband took on the
role of the older brother KIRO as in
like he included all the kids in their
games and invited them to do stuff with
them so they all look up to him a lot
um rightly so he's an amazing person but
Helm and his sister which is the next
oldest so it goes he's older brother Tom
and then his sister
um have always had a very very tight
relationship they've always been just
the best of friends they grew up they
established a business together and
worked on that for several years
um and then
they also
um just call each other daily you know
like they have a very tight Bond
um the reason why I started to get a
little jealous
was because I feel like he gives her the
attention and admiration that I wish she
would sometimes display to me but
instead it all goes to her and I just
feel like I'm kind of left out of
our relationship because it's more so
everything goes towards that one versus
ours
have you ever told them I wished one day
I wish one day you'll look at me like I
see you look at your sister
that or
um have those thoughts and I'm like yeah
you're right it is like I feel so weird
even talking about this because he's the
other woman but she's not the other
woman
you know it's not like that kind of
relationship
yeah so but but that instantly goes to a
sexualization of a relationship
yeah
um and I don't think that's I mean I'm
trusting you that's not the case here oh
no no no so I don't think it's
in his mind maybe
he goes right to a sexual relationship
and he's like no no no there's no feel I
don't have feelings for her what's the
matter with you
right but it's not about that for you it
sounds like it's about admiration and
attention
and connectivity and just being really
proud I would tell you in many ways in a
family of 10
um he's gonna have played some sort of
paternal role in her life
and almost in a kind of a weird sideways
way like she's his oldest daughter
right and there's gonna be that
pride in that
I
I don't know and you've got that trauma
Bond you've got that strict religious
upbringing that 10 kids in the house all
the chaos that comes with that there's
just going to be some connectivities how
long have y'all been married
uh we have been married now for five
years okay and that's kind of another
thing I'll give you a couple more side
notes as to why I'm starting to kind of
fill the jealous Tendencies
um we recently put up a physical
calendar in our kitchen because we have
three under three so life is kind of
chaos
yes and so
um we put up a surgical calendar to keep
track of just everyday life and get
excited about events that you write down
on there because we have days look
forward to like oh this is family
vacation etc etc so for the month of
June is really busy for us um we hung up
a blank calendar and I noticed he had
wrote a few things on there uh he wrote
when we started our garden out back and
then he only wrote one other thing which
is his sister's birthday
now in the month of June is our wedding
anniversary and our oldest child's
birthday amongst other family members
birthdays and events but he only wrote
those two things down and I don't know
why but it bothered me so badly that
that's what he remembered to put for the
month of June instead of
our wedding anniversary or our
daughter's date
or could it have could it have been oh
it's okay could it have been and again
I'm just playing devil's advocate here
could it have been that he thought y'all
would think that one through
like as you all put dates on her that
you might put dates on and he wanted to
make sure hey there's two I don't want
to forget like they were just his
um yeah he said that uh it was something
he wanted us all to sit down together as
a family and get excited about and write
together and I was like okay you know I
I can understand that
um but then like on Facebook which he
doesn't have to glorify me in any way
I'm actually used to him not doing that
because he's not typically that kind of
person but he um he put so many Facebook
posts glorifying his sister about how he
couldn't have asked for a better partner
to have a business voice that he's so
proud of her accomplishments she's
intelligent she's beautiful she's
trustworthy and I haven't got one single
thing through the last several years
and uh then on Mother's Day
um I'm kind of in charge in our house of
taking care of holidays so like for
other people like his mom my mom other
moms and family I'll get things for them
recognize them plan things out for that
holiday and then you know I'll leave it
in his hands to do that for me and our
family
so for Mother's Day
we went to his mom's house and ate
dinner with my mom and different things
of that nature well he never wished me
really a Happy Mother's day and didn't
we didn't do anything for me for
Mother's Day
um again we probably got really caught
up in everyone else but at the end of
the day we were in the car coming home
and he was texting different moms that
he knew happy Mother's Day I appreciate
you I love you thank you for the example
you've set in our lives in our company
Etc and then he found a way to
incorporate his sister into it but she's
not a mom
so in my mind I'm like how did you find
a way to incorporate your sister that's
not even a mom but you haven't wished me
a happy Mother's Day or said anything
heartfelt towards me
so that just really hurt my feelings and
I guess dug it a little bit deeper
okay
so that that would that was not cool
at all
not cool at all
um he blew that one and if he was on the
phone with me I would tell him dude you
blew that one you absolutely blew that
one uh Mother's Day I think's one of
those hard
days that is not really wise to share
that with a bunch of other people or
maybe after y'all do something special
but
um right
yeah so here's kind of the path forward
y'all been married five years
you have three kids under three
which means your marriage is zero
percent zero like it was when y'all
first started
yes
and my guess is your husband does not
know what he's doing
but he does know how to how to run a
business and he does know how to cheer
his sister on
yes he doesn't know how to please a
woman who is outside of his that weird
little construct that he grew up in he
doesn't know how to raise three little
baby kids
Because by the time he had three little
littles and he was old enough one of the
other 45 kids in his family was taking
care of him right right
and it's very common in relationships
especially with men is when they don't
feel good at one thing they just lean
into the other stuff and they just go
Full Tilt
yeah here's where this is it's not an
excuse okay just a context so here's
where this gets hard
you're gonna have to sit down and be
very very honest all at the same time
okay and but it's gonna have to be
twofold
one it's gonna have to be here are some
things that all happened in a row
that I feel I experienced
not that you did okay
I really miss the fact that not one
person told me Happy Mother's Day on
Mother's Day
nobody bought me a flower nobody said
thank you so so much
yeah
um
that breaks my heart
I even called this podcaster guy and he
said that was pretty lame
okay
and
and maybe you get one of or two of his
posts his Facebook posts and highlight
it
and say yeah you said she's beautiful
and she's great and she is all of those
things but you've never told me that
right okay so that's step one here's
step two
this is the compassionate approach
there's going to be people who hate what
I'm about to tell you okay
hi
I think it's fair for you to be very
explicit about what you would like and
about what you need
I would like you to call me every day
I would like you to tell me you're
beautiful and sometimes just hold my
hand for no reason
right I would love for you to ask me in
the morning how can I love you better
today
if you put things about your sister
online that's so amazing I'm so jealous
of how great y'all's relationship is
that is so cool and
it would really make me feel good if you
said nice things about me in public too
someday
hi okay and you're basically serving as
his teacher now here's where this is
really heart-wrenching he might say no
okay and he might not do it
he might call you crazy
and if he says oh my gosh you're crazy I
would want you to put your hand up and
stop him and say please don't dismiss
how I feel right now
that hurts my feelings too
okay
and what you're doing is you're just
teaching a young kid
who suddenly woke up and was married and
then sneezed and has three kids running
around the place
and a small business with a sister it
teaches him
here's what I need to feel safe here's
what I need to feel loved
and then you can turn it around on him
what do you need how can I better love
you
okay okay
this is going to be a risk because it
may not come true and what I'm telling
you is you're gonna wish it happened
sooner rather than later
you're gonna wish you had this
conversation now because if you find out
if he's like nah I'd rather hang out
with my sister than my wife and three
kids that's something you want to know
now
so you don't waste two decades with
somebody who's an absolute loser but I
don't think that's the case
um
I had a strange
I used to always buy flowers for
girlfriends always always I was like it
was my thing I liked buying flowers I
liked people feeling good an older
sister and saw people treat her really
well saw people treat her in ways that
made me uncomfortable I always
wanted somebody to leave my presence
feeling good about themselves
and
one day I was talking to my wife when we
were dating about flowers and she made
some off-handed comment like this
flowers
but it turns out 10 years later when I
never bought flowers
that I had misinterpreted what she said
at all and then one day she's like how
come you never have ever bought me
flowers
and I was like Oh I thought you didn't
want them and she's like no
I would love to get flowers
and it was this and again this is
something very small but
he taught me
very explicitly here's what I need
here's what I would like
and man I love doing things that make my
wife happy and bring her Joy so there is
a moment for explicit and as a culture
we expect our husbands and our wives and
our girlfriends and our boyfriends to
read our minds and just know things
and man that's cool in the movies it's
just not how it works in real life
just not how it works so take a risk
be explicit about how you feel how you
feel
and then be explicit about here's what I
want and here's what I need
and give him an opportunity to step up
I think it's okay to be jealous in the
oh my gosh I'm so jealous that they have
such a tight relationship but I also
think this is for everybody out there
if you see your husband being really
amazing to his sister or you see your
wife being really amazing to her brother
be really grateful that you married
somebody a character
and don't be afraid to speak up and let
them know how they could love you too